j'aime beaucoup ma chronique parce
qu'elle est excellente mais j'aime aussi
celle de camille combal et il ya
quelques temps dans l'émission dans sa
chronique qui nous avait montré un petit
garçon qui faisait un petit peu l'idiot
en faisant batman oui aujourd'hui
seigneurie regarder pour ceux qui
savaient revienne pas est pas si le père
louis viendra les vivants et les morts
je crois
à la vie est belle
eh bien eh bien
mais foyer
[Applaudissements]
oui oui amis des petites recherches il
s'appelle baptiste il est avec nous ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
mais que l'on sait
bon allez bertreau tu me laisses ta
place lachaud jeunes
[Applaudissements]
aller 28 ce qui va faire l'émission avec
nous moi j'ai d'ailleurs un petit peu de
loi les y faire des toilettes et cissé
pouvez vous m'appelez on commence avec
la claque visuelle de ce début d'année
oublier avatar gravity et transformers à
l'usure il passait devant le prompteur
diable
hier
on est en direct on est diffusée on est
diffusée cette émission pas si tu as
fait bah écoutez vous devriez l'ampli
peu plus le travail commence à vatry
staller baptiste que tu as dix ans oui
c'est ça un don compte à découvert la
semaine dernière tant cm1 tu travailles
bien oui c'est vrai j'ai tu regarde
souvent l'émission oui c'est vrai
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui c'est qui et
ont préféré dans l'émission bas et
palaces et enora c'est une aura bon
allez l'acl
mettez à sexe continue cyrine on dirais
tu fais pas si tu lis du tout on dirait
les pakistanais que c'est qu'ils font
des pousse pousse
[Applaudissements]
en fait jean king john key deux longs
poils pakistanais c'est normal des
mercury aller
[Applaudissements]
franck et sa trop longue pas parce qu'on
va le perdre le vieux ex aequo à tester
oui question si moi je rame pendant
incroyable ça rapporte à tour trois
balles est un peu dans les loges qui a
été le plus gentil avec toi et moi la
mer était le plus gentil toi voilà là on
voit des ficelles mais c'est énorme je
donnais ceinture rouge qui a été le
moins sympa dit franchement celui qui
t'a le moi parler dans les logs celui
que tu étais qui est elle ou moins sympa
avec toi le le plus méchant c'est celui
que j'ai vu moi oui mais celui de thèmes
celui qui a été moins sympa avec toi tu
peux dire personne personne au monde a
été gentil non on a juste donné 5 euros
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que le ps quelque chose assez
magique oui c'est universel le psc1 tu
peux péter au cameroun en suède
ça fait rire photo comprendre quelque
chose qui réunit le ps est important de
le dire je suis sûr que ce couple s'est
mis ensemble of vous n'êtes pas pour la
paix dans le monde mais pour le pédalier
[Applaudissements]
et voilà papy qui veut parler oui c'est
pas pour rien que concevoir un premier
rendez vous on dit on ce point avant
c'est là mais c'est pour ça bah oui il a
tapé telle ambiance
des sports allait un peu de vélo pour
les 2es à camiri manière dont il paraît
que ça fait péter en plus donc ah oui
vous savez vous m'avez dit je la sens
pas celle là j'ai dit ça vaut mieux
non mais c'est pas de la jeta portrait
l'histoire est arrivé au théâtre faisait
systématiquement un gros pays se tourner
vers sa voisine que ça fait rien madame
vous n'aurez qu'à dire que c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire du sport du sport
c'est que tu vois arriver tu sais c'est
comme si tu étais au lycée ça arrive au
mur arriver dès jeudi
ça va y aller de danse m el hiba quand
c'est fini et je sens la seule sans
lacets